in lawrence south carolina a major
effort is underway to turn
a former klu klux klan meeting hall into
a center for diversity and
reconciliation
adriana diaz introduces us to the
unlikely team leading that change and
we do have to warn you that some of
these images are upsetting
quiet lauren south carolina has harbored
an open secret
for decades this once a segregated
cinema
the echo theater was long a meeting
place for white supremacists
inside the redneck shop which sold
confederate flags
nazi propaganda and ku klux klan apparel
local reverend david kennedy had been
fighting to close the shop
for years it has always represented
racism and humiliation for the black
community
humiliation and terror kennedy knows the
oral history of his own
great great grand uncles lynching
as i listened to the story and i
connected with the picture
i felt like it was me hanging from the
rope
the theater was a symbol of that hate
this meeting in 2006 included members of
the kkk
the aryan nation and the nazi party
but the theater's destiny took an almost
cinematic turn
the building was owned by a reformed
klansman who sold it to a black pastor
who helped him through tough times that
pastor
was reverend kennedy we knew if we
owned it it would never be a cuckoo's
claim written in shop again
but the power of the building
still lives every time i go in there i
have to brace myself
the shop closed in 2012 and the
reverend's now trying to
transform the theater into a symbol of
love
with the help of his new beginning
missionary baptist church
and an unexpected ally the team ever
24 year old reagan freeman i believe in
this i do not know why
it caught on to me i mean it's the right
thing to do reagan
is a breath of fresh air he's young
he's energetic he stays pumped up there
is a reckoning taking place in america
freeman was in college when this 2018
60-minute story
changed his life's course oprah
winfrey's report on the memorial
honoring the thousands of african
americans lynched in the u.s
revealed an ugly truth about freeman's
home county
of lawrence every name has its own story
yes that's right
liza cowan was lynched in lawrence
county south carolina
she was lynched here and that was never
taught to me as i was growing up
it sat with me and it bothered me to no
end so
was it on that side or that side so he
did some digging learned about reverend
kennedy's goal for the theater
and offered to help i cold called
reverend kennedy for him to
take a chance and you know let me be a
part of this and to help his church you
know push the rock
up the hill it's the honor of a lifetime
freeman is now the executive director of
the echo project
the effort to convert the theater into a
museum and memorial for diversity and
reconciliation
it will display the racist relics it
once housed
everything we have you know ranging from
the artifacts to the oral histories of
the people who lived this
it illustrates that this is not ancient
history it's our responsibility
to really tell the truth here how does
it feel to have a young
southern white man care about
this mission in this deep way it's a
sign of
hope the echo project has raised more
than
four hundred thousand dollars but needs
millions
reverend kennedy is undeterred good
love got the pump we're at a critical
time
if our democracy is going to be saved it
must not be saved
with racism and hatred it must be saved
by love love
and the people who spread it for cbs
this morning
i'm adriana diaz
[Music]
great job adriana yes heck of a story
you tell a good story guys and you never
know where it's going to land he's
watching the piece and it inspires him
to get involved
exactly very well done thank you so much
adriana you're watching cbs this morning
we'll be right back